the horrors of the war in ukraine are
undeniable and often unimaginable at
least to people consuming media outside
of russia last week's united nations
resolution successfully kicked russia
out of the un human rights council but
it was far from unanimous 93 mostly
western or richer nations supported the
resolution 24 voted against and 76
either weren't present to vote or
abstained among them south africa its
president has laid some blame with nato
that its eastward expansion
would lead to greater not less
instability in the region the world
order can sometimes look different
depending on perspective there are many
countries that are very dependent on
russia that have privately told us told
me very directly
we agree with you
but there are limits on what we can say
and do the nato-led campaigns in
afghanistan and libya have led to calls
of hypocrisy from many developing
nations one of baptism
is all over the place here
and it includes
the israel-palestine issue the
the issues and
other interventions countries like
nigeria have signed arms deals with
russia after being shunned by the west
over human rights concerns
india too relies on russian arms we are
for dialogue and diplomacy
we are for urgent cessation of violence
delhi resisting western pressure to take
sides the support given by the soviet
union and then russia
in the security council on the kashmir
issue for india has been very pivotal
the position of russia's ally china
perhaps a factor for african nations
that rely on it for investment to see
russia on part of many countries
as representing anti-colonialism
there is a conflation of anti-colonial
with anti-westernism but russia's
critics argue this invasion is simply
part of a push to re-establish its
colonial conquests redmond shannon
global news london